un inmenso surtido de pañales para
adultos mayores son la insignia en este
supermercado los hay de todos los
colores y para todos los gustos venir a
comprar estos productos ya no es
vergonzoso otros lugares lo llevan aún
más lejos en esta farmacia no sólo se
venden pañales para bebés aquí el adulto
mayor es el rey
hay ilustraciones parecidas a los
dibujos animados y en otros paquetes hay
fotografías de adultos mayores con muy
buena salud estos productos transmiten
una imagen alegre así las personas no se
sienten avergonzadas cuando los compran
aquí es una pequeña ciudad apacible en
el oeste de japón situada al pie del
monte de aysén de sus 10 mil habitantes
4000 tienen más de 65 años hace unos
años los pañales representaban el 10 por
ciento de los desechos generados por la
población
250 toneladas anuales en este hogar para
adultos mayores el 90% de los residentes
los utiliza pero la institución
estableció una estrategia ecológica
local un sistema de reciclaje selectivo
que ha sido una pequeña revolución
de este lado está en las bolsas de
pañales usados y aquí está el resto de
los desechos combustibles
dentro de estas bolsas especialmente
concebidas para aislar los malos olores
esta tarde se recogen 185 kilos de
pañales usados en lugar de ser quemados
son transformados en una fábrica
acondicionada especialmente para la
tarea aquí dos empleados trabajan a
tiempo completo desinfección secado
corte lo que se obtiene después de esta
primera etapa se comprime para formar
estas pequeñas bolitas conocidas como
pellets prácticamente inodoras
es un valor que se parece un poco al del
plástico o al del vinilo fundido
es realmente leve
los pelets son llevados a los baños
públicos de joaquín
que se calientan desde esta área
reciclar los pañales resulta más barato
que el combustible o el gas que
tradicionalmente se usan para calentar
el agua de los baños japoneses y sobre
todo el procedimiento es más ecológico
muy bien
instalamos una válvula filtrante para
reducir el humo al máximo cuando sale
es bueno para el medio ambiente
al interior de los baños termales a los
clientes les entusiasma la idea la
ciudad redujo un 20% sus emisiones de
dióxido de carbono el equivalente a 30
toneladas de co2 por año
no hay mal olor el agua es de buena
calidad es un poco salada me parece que
no está nada mal
el hecho de reciclar los pañales es algo
muy bueno
no me molesta para nada
el creador de este producto hace unos 15
años fue el alcalde de la ciudad para él
lo que está en juego es el futuro de
joaquín
lo que realmente me preocupa es la
distancia entre la cantidad de personas
mayores y de jóvenes que trabajan
cuando una ciudad envejece la producción
y el consumo disminuyen progresivamente
en tan sólo 30 años hockey ha perdido
2.000 habitantes
[Música]
una vez a la semana en este salón
municipal unos 15 adultos mayores se
reúnen para una clase de deporte
aquí no hay jóvenes
los domingos por ejemplo no vemos a los
niños jugar afuera
cuando es preocupante veo cada vez más
casas abandonadas
para las personas que viven aquí desde
hace mucho tiempo se ha vuelto muy
triste
con 88 años ya sueco hachita ni es la
mayor de las clases de deporte junto con
su esposo de 90 años nunca ha dejado de
sembrar arroz y verduras tiene una salud
de hierro y una autonomía absoluta
entre nosotros hacemos bromas y decimos
que no conocemos a nadie que utilice
pañales
pero llegará el momento
y hay que hacerlo
ahora los pañales son muy prácticos
acaso con galleta ni sabe acerca del
tema durante mucho tiempo cuido de su
madre que falleció a los 108 años
en esa época en vez de pañales
utilizábamos telas hechas de antiguos
kimonos
al igual que el hacking en todo el
archipiélago varias municipalidades han
empezado a reciclar los pañales de sus
adultos mayores así japón reduce su
dependencia de las energías fósiles y se
convierte en un país un poco más verde